once again the eyes of the world
are on minneapolis the city braced for
the trial
of the former police officer accused of
murdering george floyd
tense in the knowledge this will be a
defining moment
for america the intersection where
george floyd died
has become a sacred space a police-free
zone
with heightened emotions by day
increased shootings
and gang violence by night
in the coming weeks the jury will have
to decide if what happened here was
murder
if police officer derek shovin intended
to kill george floyd
when he knelt on his neck for nearly
nine minutes
ken rantz who served on minneapolis
police conduct review panel
is clear this trial is a big test for
america
the us is at a is at a racial crossroads
and it's one of the things that we've
never truly addressed
as a nation and until we do it is going
to continue
to pull us apart and i've reviewed my
share of cases but this
was the worst the most egregious
violation of civil rights i've ever
witnessed
and for eight minutes and 46 seconds
he had his knee on this man's neck
i've i've asked myself
what was his intent when was enough
enough
he had eight minutes and 46 seconds to
think about his actions
was he gonna let george floyd up after
nine minutes
after 10 minutes what was he waiting was
he waiting for help derek chauvin is
appearing in court in person
in the first criminal trial to be
televised in minnesota
released on a one million dollar bail
the former officer pleads not guilty
to the murder and manslaughter of george
floyd
it's alleged derrick chauvin has a
history of excessive force as a police
officer
i'm good good to meet you i went to meet
lashon braddock
who was arrested by derek shovin in
2013.
after a mistaken identity the mental
health worker
later filed a complaint about his
aggressive treatment
so i went down on my knees and then i
went down to the ground and it jumped
all over me
then they put the cuffs on me super
tight and i kept complaining that these
cups were tight
can you loosen them please and then they
were saying they're not built for
comfort you know
and i understand that i'm like but
they're cutting off my circulation you
know
and they kept repeating the same thing
and they still hadn't told me why i was
even pulled over at that time
how did it make you feel to be treated
like that uh
like an animal like i wasn't like i was
like my life didn't matter
when you saw that video did you see
yourself in george floyd
yes because he was just on his neck for
no reason
and he was already subdued in the
handcuffs like
and pretty much i was in the same
position
it's scary because you don't know if
you're gonna live it makes me feel like
if they would have took me seriously
or all the other people that complained
against him seriously
that it may not have gotten to the point
where someone died
sean said his complaint essentially went
nowhere but it was only after
george floyd was killed that he learned
he wasn't alone there were
more than a dozen other people who filed
official complaints about derek
chauvin's behavior as a police officer
lachan's complaint wasn't upheld and nor
were the others where the data
is publicly available in court the judge
has ruled to limit the evidence about
previous incidents allowed in the trial
michelle gross has collected the data of
police complaints
and deaths of citizens involving law
enforcement in the state of minnesota
since 2000. i knew the history
of derrick shoven in fact when i saw the
video
the first thing i noticed was i thought
that looks like derek chovin
oh my gosh there's certain officers
whose names you hear over and over again
and his was one of them
the minneapolis police department is not
commenting on derrick sheldon's case
protests last summer revealed the
fragile relationship between the force
and the community
a police precinct burnt to the ground as
public trust
went up in smoke with angry calls
for an overhaul of the system where were
the checks and the balances
where were the the reviews where were
the psychological
evaluations you know what might some of
those other complaints have
you know led to and were they addressed
where this individual could still be on
the streets
harming people and that's
completely unacceptable and
unfortunately
black people in this country bear the
bear the brunt of that
the heavy security outside court is a
fraction
of what we'll see in the coming weeks
two thousand members of the national
guard will be mobilized by the time of
the verdict
with law enforcement ramping up
throughout the trial
in court derek chovin's lawyers will
argue he was just doing his job and
following his training as a police
officer
it's expected they will seek to
discredit george floyd's character
and claim his death was related to drugs
and a medical condition
the prosecution will say none of this is
relevant that george floyd wouldn't have
died
had a knee not been on his neck for
nearly nine minutes
george floyd isn't here to see the
impact his death has had on the world
and for many this trial is about far
more than one life
it's seen as a verdict on america's
stance on police brutality
against its black citizens
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis